This is Jocko podcast number 43 with Echo Charles and me,
Jocko Willink.
All the lads have gone out to play at being soldiers far away.
They won't be back for many a day then.
Some won't be back any morning.
All the lassies who laughing,
we're when hearts were light and lads were here.
They go sad.
I'd wandering hither and there they pray and watch for the morning.
Every house has its vacant bed every night when sounds are dead.
Some woman yearns for the pillowed head of Him who marched out in the morning of
all the lads who've gone out to play,
there's some will return and some who will stay.
There's some,
we'll be back most any day,
but some won't wake up in the morning.
Good Evening Echo.
Good evening.
That poem right there is called the lads away and it's from a book called the
glory of the trenches at Coningsby Dawson.
It actually got this book and original copy of this book
from a trooper from Jesse trooper up from Canada.
And he sent me this book.
And like I said,
it's the actual first printing,
beautiful copy and it has that smell,
that old book,
a musty smell.
It's one of those books where you can actually smell the age and you can smell
the lessons learned and you can smell the wisdom inside of it.
And
it's a different view.
It's a different feel.
And I found it to be very fascinating.
And the,
the intro to the book was actually written by Dawson's father.
So the,
so the intro of the book,
you know Dawson is the guy that wrote the book Coningsby.
Dot.
Dawson is the guy that wrote the book.
Well,
his dad wrote the intro to the book and he kind of kicks it off.
And here's some of the highlights of that.
He says,
I've already stated the conditions under which this book of my sons was
produced.
He was wounded in the end of June,
1917 in the fear struggle before lens.
He was at once removed to a base hospital.
And later to a military hospital in London.
There was in grave danger of amputation of the right arm,
but this was happily avoided as soon as he could use his hand.
He was commandeered by the Lord High Commissioner of Canada,
right and important paper detailing the history of the Canadian Forces in France
and Flanders.
Okay,
and he goes on to talk about how they came up with the name of the book and they
go through a different couple different titles and they they settle on this,
this title,
the glory of the change trenches.
Lastly,
we decided on the glory of the trenches
as the most expressive of his aim.
He felt that a great deal,
too much had been said about the squalor,
filth,
discomfort,
and suffering of the trenches.
Now,
clearly that stuff that I've talked about,
and so this should or tell you,
that's what I'm talking about.
This is a different take on world war one because he's saying,
look,
we've heard enough about the squalor,
the filth,
that discomfort.
I'm going to talk about the glory of the trenches.
He pointed out that a very poppy little war book,
which we were reading had six paragraphs in the first 60 pages,
which describe an unpleasant detailed.
The vermin is condition of the men as if there were this were the chief thing to
be remarked concerning them.
He held bet.
It was a mistake for a writer to lay too much on the streets,
too much stress on the horrors of war.
The effect was bad.
Physiologically.
It frightened the parents of soldiers.
It was equally bad for the enlisted man himself for creating a false impression
in his mind.
We all knew that war was horrible,
but as a rule,
the soldier thought little of his feature in this lot.
Okay.
The real soldiers thoughts were concerned with other things.
He was engaged in spiritual acts and this is what I'm talking about.
This is a different cut.
He was accomplishing spiritual purposes.
As truly as the Margaret of faith and religion.
He was moved by spiritual input impulses,
the,
the evocation of duty,
the loyal dependence of comradeship,
the spirit of sacrifice,
look complete surrender of the body to the will of the soul.
Yeah.
This was the side of war,
which men needed most to recognize.
They needed it,
not only because it was the true side,
but because nothing else could kindle and sustain the enduring flame of heroism
in men's hearts.
So he's looking at this,
it's called the glory of the trenches in this what happens in the trenches.
He's like a,
he's like a religion is like a spiritual thing.
Which another thing that drew me to this,
cause you know,
I talk all the time about how there's the most beautiful things in war.
I mean there's not wall,
most horrible things,
but there's also these beautiful things.
And so I can see he's very focused on what those things are.
Hmm.
While some aired and exhibiting nothing but the brutalities of war,
others aired by sentimental Ising war.
He admitted that it was perfectly possible to paint a portrait of a soldier with
an aura of a saint,
but it would not be a representative portrait.
It would be eclectic,
the result of selection and elimination.
So he's saying like on the one hand you get these books that paint this crazy,
brutal side of war.
The other side,
you get them painting soldiers as saints and neither one is true,
which I will totally agree with.
You know,
we,
we do have a definite tendency to do that in literature or people that write
about war,
they want to write about,
you know,
they make everyone look like the best guy ever.
None of us are.
We all have faults.
Yeah.
Back to the book,
the ordinary soldiers and intensely human creature with an endearing blend of
faults and virtues.
The romantic method of portraying him not only misrepresented him,
but its result is far less impressive than a portrait painted in the firm lines
of reality.
So they do all this to make the guy look like a saint,
but the,
what's real is actually more amazing.
There's an austere grand juror in the reality of what he is and does,
which needs no fine gilding from the sentimentalist to depict him as Sir Galahad
and holy armor is a serious offense as to exhibit him as a Kaliban,
which is,
it's from,
it's from Shakespeare from the temp to see.
He's like the,
the ultimate bad guy in the Shakespeare's play,
the temp,
the tempest.
It's a total beast.
Um,
so you can't portray the person has Galahad.
You can't,
you can't,
you know,
again,
portray him as a saint.
Okay?
Each method fails of truth and all that.
The soldier needs to be known about him,
that men should honor him,
is the truth.
Okay?
War,
a hot new air,
which men breathed,
produced new energies and forms of thought.
Men were rediscovering themselves,
their own forgotten nobilities.
The Leighton nobilities in all men bound together in the daily obedience of self
surrender urged by conditions of their tasks to regard duty as an inexhaustible
confronted by the pedal.
This destruction of the body.
They were forced into recognition of the spiritual values of life.
So faced with what they were facing,
a World War One,
and we've talked about that over and over again,
you're facing death and these guys,
these soldiers are,
are forced to look at their spiritual self in the common conventional use of the
term.
These men were not religious.
There was much in their speech and in their conduct,
which would outrage this standards of narrow pirates ism.
So,
Hey,
these guys,
not goody two shoes.
Traditional creeds and forms of faith had scant authority for them.
Yeah,
but they had made their own a sure.
Faith then lives in creeds.
So what they discover on the battlefield is even stronger than [inaudible].
Okay.
Didn't what the Dean,
what the churches say.
It was an,
it was expressed not in words,
but acts.
They had fried their souls from the tyrannies of time and the fear of death.
They had accomplished in deed that very emancipation of the soul,
which is the essential doctrine of all religions,
which all religions urge on men,
but which few men really achieve.
However earnestly they profess forms of pious faith.
That's pretty amazing.
It's a pretty amazing viewpoint that what you find out on the battlefield is
spiritually,
spiritually stronger.
Yeah.
Didn't what you find in the church.
Hmm.
Back to the book.
This was the true glory of the trenches.
Yeah.
They were the cavalry's of a new redemption being wrought out for men by soiled
unconscious Christ's is.
That's what the soldiers were soiled.
Dirty unconscious means they don't even know it.
Christ's
yeah.
And as from that ancient cavalry with its agony of shame,
torture,
and dereliction,
there flowed a flood of light,
which made a new dawn for the world.
So from these obscure crucifixions,
there would come to men,
a new revelation of the splendor of the human soul,
the true divinity that dwells in man,
but God made manifest in the flesh by acts of valor,
heroism and self sacrifice,
which transcend the instincts and promptings of the flesh.
Okay.
And bear witness to the indestructible life of the spirit.
That's heavy.
Yes.
That's,
that's just eight.
Like I said,
this viewpoint is,
I can totally understand where it's coming from and it expresses a lot of the
things that I think,
I haven't thought about it to this degree though.
You know,
calling that be basically,
it's calling the deaths of soldiers on the battlefield crucifixions right?
Yeah.
And that God is made manifest in the flesh that these guys,
when they say,
make these sacrifices,
it's like a glimpse of God.
These acts of valor and heroism.
And it's just very powerful.
Now that's wraps up,
you know,
the,
the intros longer than that obviously.
Um,
but now we're going to go to the book itself,
which again is written by this soldier Dawson and it actually starts with his
training.
So,
and he was,
he was from England and he lived in Canada and,
but he ends up joining the military cause you know,
Canada was,
uh,
was uh,
w w w supporting and helping Britain in a war and he'd actually traveled to New
York.
He'd lived all over the place and,
but now he's,
he's going to boot camp
and we'll take it back to the book.
When I had been medically examined past as fit,
had don the uniform and commenced my training,
I learnt what the enduring of hardship was.
No experience on active service has equaled the humiliation and severity of
those first months of soldiering.
We were sneered at clean stables,
groomed horses,
rode stripped saddles,
stripped saddle for 12 miles at the trot,
attended lectures,
studied till past midnight 10.
We're up on the first parade at six o'clock.
No previous civilian efficiency or prominent stood up us in any stead.
We started robbed of all importance.
I love that we started rob devolve voluntary,
so you know that thing you have that an ego.
Yeah,
it's gone.
Just to get rid of that and only gained a new importance by our power to hang on
and develop a new efficiency as soldiers.
And you've heard me say that before,
like when I joined the military,
that's one of my favorite things about it and I was like a blank slate.
Like everything you did in your past,
all the,
all the stuff you've been through,
little trouble,
things you've done,
it's all gone.
What matters now is what you do here.
When men went sick,
they were labeled scrim Shanker's and struck off the course.
It was an offense.
It wasn't a fence to let your body interfere with your duty.
If it tried to,
you must ignore it.
If a man caught cold and Kingston,
what would he not catch in the trenches?
Very many went down under physical under the physical ordeal of the class.
That started,
I don't think more than a third past.
The lukewarm soldier and the pink tea hero who simply wanted to swank a uniform,
we're eventually choked off.
It was a test of pluck even more than of strength or intelligence.
The same test that a man would be subjected to all the time at the front in a
word,
it's sorted out.
The fellows who had guts,
okay.
Guts isn't a particularly polite
word,
but I have come increasingly to appreciate it's splendid significance.
The possessor of this much coveted quality is the kind of Ada who when his legs
are smitten,
we'll fight upon his stumps.
And I actually was,
when I read this,
I was like,
man,
well is there some archaic term of idiot?
Why is he using that word?
And there was none.
Like he means that's what it means is like a guy used,
we say this,
the seal training,
like if you're going to be stupid,
you've got to be tough.
And then that's kind of what he's saying.
Like these guys will go and they will not stop.
And that's what guts is
the Tommys and that's a slang word for the British soldiers whom we were going
to command would be like that.
If we weren't like it,
we wouldn't be any good as officers.
This artillery school had a violent way of sifting out a man's moral worth.
Okay.
You hadn't much conceit left by the end of it.
So what?
Uh,
I can only imagine,
you know,
we have a very politically correct military system now and it's getting,
I can't imagine what the soldiers went through.
I mean just an unleashing these veterans on them coming out and trying to get
them ready for war.
I bet it was brutal.
And it sounds like it was brutal and it sounds like it did in a very effective
job of getting rid of the week of making your ego completely go away.
You know,
getting rid of any form of conceit that you had.
Hm.
Now he continues on the book,
but I'm going to move a little bit forward here to where he's moving towards the
front and we'll go back to the book.
After trudging about six miles,
we arrived at the camp and found that it was out of food and that all the tents
were occupied.
We stretched out our sleeping bags on the ground and went to bed supper lists.
We'd had no food all day.
Next morning we were told that we ought to jump on an ammunition,
Laurie,
if we want it to go any further on our journey.
Nobody seemed to want us particularly and no one could give us the least infer
information as to where our division was.
It was another lesson if that were needed of our total unimportance.
So these guys are looking to find where they're supposed to report to so you can
go fight in the war and people were like,
Hey,
I got no,
no time for you.
Go figure it out.
While we were waiting on the roadside in Australian brigade of artillery passed
by,
the men's faces were dreary with fatigue.
The gunners were dismounted and marched as in a trance.
The harness was muddy.
The steel rusty,
the horses lean and discouraged.
We understood that they were pulling out from an offensive in which they'd
received a bad cutting up to my overstrained imagination.
It seemed that the men had the vision of death in their eyes.
Towards the evening,
the thunder of the guns had into an ominous roar.
We pass through villages,
disfigured by Shell.
Fire civilians became more rare and more aged.
Cattle disappeared utterly from the landscape.
Fields were furrowed with abandoned trensor's in in front of which Hong
entanglements of wire mounted orderlies splashed along Solon roads at an
inpatient trot here and there.
We came across improvise bureau of acts of infantry far away against the horizon
towards which we traveled.
Hun,
flares and rockets were going up.
Hopeless Stoicism,
unalterable desolation.
That was my first impression,
okay.
The landscape was getting increasingly muddy.
It became a sea of mud dispatch riders on motorbikes traveled where leave their
feet dragging to save themselves from falling.
Everything was splashed with filth and corruption.
One marveled that the cleanliness of the sky,
okay.
Trees were blasted and seem to be sinking out of sight.
In this war created slew of despondency.
We came to a brow of a hill in the valley was something that I recognized the
last time I had seen.
It wasn't an etching in a shop window in Newark,
New Jersey.
It was a town from the midst of who's battered ruins a splinter tower,
straight sword against the sky,
leaning far out from the tower so that it seemed she must drop,
was a statue of the Virgin with the Christ in her arms.
It was a superstition with the French and I remembered that so long as she did
not fall,
things would go well with the allies.
As we watched a shale screamed over the gaping roofs and a column of smoke went
up.
As we entered the streets,
Tommy's more polluted than miners crept out from the skeletons of houses.
They lent listlessly against sagging doorways to watch us pass.
If we asked for information as to where our division was,
they shook their heads stupidly to indifferent with weariness,
to reply.
For the next three nights we slept by our wits and got our food by foraging.
Okay,
so we know,
I mean,
we know this is world war one.
We know it's a night.
We know it's an absolute nightmare.
It's an absolute nightmare and it,
you know what was surprising to me,
you know this guy's an officer and he has no idea what he's doing.
He's just a walking around and people are so despondent from the war that they
just don't even care.
Hmm.
Back to the book,
there was a headquarters near by WHO's battalion was in the line.
I struck up liaison with its officers and at times went into the crowded tent,
which was their mass to get warm.
Runners would come there at all hours of day and night bringing messages from
the front.
They were usually well-spent.
Sometimes they gassed,
but they had,
but they all had the invincible determination to carry on.
After they delivered their message,
they would lie down in the mud and go to sleep like dogs.
The moment the reply was ready,
they would lurch to their feet,
throwing off their weariness as if it were a thing to be conquered and despised.
Go ahead and read that one again.
The two.
These guys are dog tired dates get laid down in the mud.
Somebody is preparing a reply for these messages and then the moment the reply
was met it ready,
they would lurch to their feet,
throwing off their weirdness as though it were a thing to be conquered and
despised.
I appreciate now as never before.
I appreciated now as never before the lesson of guts that I had been taught at
Kingston,
the other side of the town,
the ravages of the war were far more marked all the way along the roadside where
clumps of little crosses,
French,
English,
German planted above the hurried graves of brave fellows who had fallen AAMP
loans.
Ambulances were picking their way,
weirdly turning with the last night's toll of wounded.
We saw newly dead men and horses pulled to one side who had been caught in the
darkness by the enemies harassing fire in places in places the country had holes
the size of quarries where mines it exploded and shells from large caliber guns
and detonated bed limb was raging upfront.
Shell's went screaming over us.
Seeking out victims in the back country to have been there by oneself would have
been most disturbing.
But the men about me seem to regard it as perfectly ordinary and normal.
I steadied myself by their example.
Hmm.
It's,
it's,
it's interesting because we're talking about this and it sounds like hell and
they're not even in the front yet.
They're not on the front lines.
This is behind.
Mm.
That's something also we were talking about today.
Like you can see these guys,
whatever pain and suffering they're feeling,
they're not showing it in the end.
He knows he can't show it.
And that kind of bolsters them all and makes them all stronger.
Yeah.
Back to the book about seven o'clock as we were resting the evening hate
commenced
in those days.
The evening hate was a regular habit with the hun.
He knew our country better than we did for,
he had retired from it every evening.
He used to search out all communication trenches and likely battery positions
with any quantity of shells.
So seven o'clock at night,
the Germans would just,
they knew all the positions because they had surrendered them.
So then they would just start dropping bombs,
dropping artillery on the known positions that they knew.
They knew that the charges,
what did they built them?
Horrible.
His idea was to rob us of our morale.
I wish he might've seen how Bisley,
how much,
how abysmally.
He failed to do it down our narrow valley,
like a flight of arrows.
The shells screamed and whistles where they struck the ground look like
resurrection day with the dead,
elbowing their way into daylight and forcing back the earth from their eyes.
Okay.
There were actually many dead men just beneath the surface,
and as the ground was plowed up,
the smell of corruption became distinctly unpleasant.
So these guys are buried.
They're buried in whatever,
four or five feet of dirt and the shells come in and dig them up.
Okay?
Presently the shells began to go dud.
So imagine this,
you're,
you're hearing these beggars closing and then she,
Michelle's hit and there's,
there's no explosion.
You know what that means?
It means it's gas.
We realized that these were gas shells,
a thin bluish vapor spread throughout the valley and breathing became
oppressive.
Then like stallions kicking in the stalls.
The heavy guns on the ridge above us opened up.
So now the friendly guns start to open up.
It was fine to hear them stamping their defiance.
It made one want to get grips with his aggressors.
In the brief silence is one could hear our chaps laughing.
So I want you to imagine this.
This is awesome.
You're getting shelled,
you're getting crushed.
There's dead bodies coming up from the soil.
There's gas in the air.
And,
and here we go.
In the brief silences,
one could hear our chaps laughing.
Okay?
The danger seem to fill them with a wild excitement.
Every time a shell came near them and missed,
they would taunt the unseen huns for their propor gunnery giving what they
considered necessary corrections.
Five minutes more left old caulk.
If you'd only dropped 50 you'd get us.
So he's giving corrections to the guns.
These men didn't know what fear was,
or if they did,
they kept it to themselves.
And these were the chaps whom I was to order.
So we haven't heard too much about that.
And I,
you know,
Tony's Tony and they've talked about it,
being beaten gets shot at being really close calls,
situations and like everyone's laughing and it's,
it does happen.
World War One don't hear much about it,
but here you go.
Okay.
Unbelievable.
And that's part of the way that military that you do,
not just military,
but any bands or you get a bad situation.
You know,
a little humor goes a long,
long way.
A little humor goes a long way.
Back to the book,
we entered a trench,
and this is,
by the way,
this is,
I'm obviously not reading the entire book.
I'm going to some highlights.
So there's a little bit of a skip,
you know,
uh,
time here as they,
as a move towards more towards the front,
back to the book,
we entered a trench,
holes were scooped out in the side of it,
just large enough to shelter a manned crouching each hole contained a sleeping
soldier who looked as dead as the occupant occupant with mechanical.
Some of the holes had been blown in.
All you saw of the late occupant was a protruding arm or leg at best.
There was a horrid similarity between the dead and the living.
It seemed that the walls of the trenches had been built out of corpses for one,
recognize the uniforms of French and the huns.
So you're in the trenches,
but,
and you're protected somewhat,
but you got to dig another hole into the wall of the trench.
And some of those guys get buried and killed and the bodies are just,
they're
really,
I mean,
talk about hell yeah.
Hell yeah.
Yeah.
Back to the book,
the enemy's Schilling was growing more intense,
as was always the way on the soum.
So are there at the song,
the bowel whistle,
when we were bringing in our,
when we were bringing out our wounded,
a good,
many of our trenches were directly on filleted.
And if you don't know what that is on filleted is like,
if you can imagine a line of people and you were shooting down the line of
people and how much more exposed you are in that situation.
So picture,
if I told you to shoot a tin,
uh,
some of these tin cans and I lined them up in a straight line perpendicular to
you,
you'd have to aim at each individual one and you might hit it.
You might not.
If we put them all in a big line where they're,
where they're parallel to you are there,
there they go down the same gun target line that you have.
Yeah,
you can.
If you hit one,
you might hit too.
You might hit three,
you might hit all of them with one shot.
And so this is a bad situation to be in where you never want to have the enemy.
So they're basically on your flank and you're lined up for them to shoot at you.
It's a,
it's a nightmare.
Shell's burst just behind the parapet when they didn't burst on it when they
didn't burst on it.
It was about this point in my breaking in that I received a blow to the head and
thank God for the man who invented the steel helmets.
He's getting hit with some shrapnel.
Knight came down and we found that our carriage had no lights.
It must've been nearing dawn when I was away,
and again,
um,
I skipped a little bit,
but here,
here we are obviously in a carriage.
It must've been nearing dawn when I was awakened by the distant thunder of guns.
I crouched in my corner,
cold and cramped,
trying to visualize the terror of it.
I asked myself whether I was afraid,
not of death.
I told myself,
but of being afraid,
yes,
most horribly,
he was most horribly afraid,
not of death or being wounded.
He was afraid of being afraid.
Yeah.
This first experience in no man's land did away with my last flabby fear that if
I was afraid I would show it.
One is often afraid and he soldier who was searched.
The contrary may not be a liar,
but he certainly does not speak the truth.
Physical fear is to deeply rooted,
to be overcome by any amount of training.
It remains then to train a man in spiritual pride so that when he fears,
nobody knows it.
Okay.
Cowardice is contagious.
It has been said that no battalion is braver than it's least brave member.
Yeah.
Military courage therefore is a form of unselfishness.
Courage is a form of unselfishness.
It is practiced that it may save the weaker men's lives and uphold their honor.
But worst thing you can say of a man out on the front is it he doesn't play the
game
that doesn't have necessity mean he fails to do his duty.
Listen to this.
That doesn't mean he fails to do his duty.
What it means is that he fails to do a bit more than his duty.
Hmm.
When a man plays the game,
he does things which it requires a braver man than himself to accomplish.
He never knows when he's done.
He acknowledges no limit to his cheerfulness and strength.
Whatever his rank,
he holds his life less valuable than that of the humblest.
He laughs at danger,
not because he does not dread it,
but because he or learned that there are ailments more terrible and less curable
than death.
Ailments,
more terrible and less curable than death,
and that ailment is cowardice.
Until I became a part of the war,
I was a doubter of the nobility and all others,
and a skeptic as regards to myself,
the growth of my personal vision was complete.
When I recognize that the capacity of heroism is latent in everybody and only
awaits the bigness of the opportunity to call it out,
different,
take
different take in.
And obviously,
you know,
uh,
we've talked about world war one and unless,
I mean obviously he's not the only person that felt this way about things.
And if he,
if this wasn't at least a,
a fairly normal attitude to have,
there's no way that world war one could have continued on the way it did because
people would have been saying,
no,
this is ridiculous.
Ridiculous.
We just lost another 80,000 casualties.
We lost another 100,000.
These are battles where tens of thousands of people or casualties in one day and
two days.
So if people didn't have this kind of attitude that this was their duty,
the,
they wouldn't have been able to maintain that type of,
that type of
pace.
And
I don't even know whether to say I'm
impressed by that or disgusted by it or disturbed.
I didn't aid,
not disgusted,
but disturbed by it,
disturbed by it,
and I would say all the time you,
this is the war that I,
I,
I would not want to fight it wouldn't want to fight it because this is the
attitude is,
okay,
your duty is to go get killed when we call and it doesn't matter how good I say
this all time.
It doesn't matter how good your tactics are.
It doesn't matter how good of a shooter you are.
It doesn't matter how good of a leader you are because when we say go,
you're going to get,
your troops are going to do what we say.
You're going to go over the top and recharge the machine guns and guys are going
to get mowed down.
Okay.
Now he goes into a little bit more about,
yeah,
some of the battle
back to the book.
All this April high above the shouting of the guns are larks,
the larks sing joyously,
the scarlet of the poppies,
the song of the larks,
the lamp shining on the altar are the only external signs of the unconquerable
happy religion,
which lies in the hearts of our men.
Their religion is the religion of heroism,
which they have learned in the glory of the trenches.
There a line
from William William Morris is earthly paradise,
which is like a long epic poem.
It's almost like a novel which used to haunt me,
especially in the early days when I was first experiencing what war really
meant.
It reads as follows of Heaven or hell,
I have no power to sing.
I cannot ease the burden of your fears or make quick coming death a little
thing.
It's the last line that makes me smile rather quietly or make quick coming death
a little thing.
I smile because the souls who wear khaki have learned to do just that.
These guys,
this fear of death that people have and this poem that says,
Hey,
you can't make quick death quick coming death.
You can't make that into a little thing.
It's going to be huge and ominous.
Guess what?
These guys are okay with it.
Back to the book,
how typical he is of the days before the war when the people had only pin pricks
to endure and consequently didn't exert themselves to be brave or big sacrifice,
which bankrupts one's life is always more bearable than the little inevitable
annoyances of sickness,
disappointment and dying in a bed.
Yeah.
The burden of our fears has slipped from our shoulders in our attempt to do
something for others.
Yeah.
The unbelievable and long coveted miracle has happened at last to every soul who
has grasped his chance of heroism.
Quick coming death has become a fifth rate calamity.
Think about that.
Quick coming down.
Yeah,
you're good.
Whatever.
You're no big deal to me.
You're a fifth rate calamity.
Back to the book in saying this,
I do not mean to glorify war.
War can never be anything but be sleek and damage it.
Deep back.
It dates back to the jungle,
but there are two kinds of war.
There's the kind that a highway,
men wages when he pounces from the bushes and assaults a defenseless woman.
Then there's also the kind where you wage when you go to rescue her.
The highway man can't expect to come out of that fight with a loftier morality,
but you can.
Our chaps never wanted to fight.
They hate fighting.
It's that hatred of the thing
they are compelled to do that makes them so terrible.
He goes back and he's talking now about that wooden figure of Christ that he had
seen the wooden Christ gaze down from them on his cross where they suffering,
which 2000 years ago he had shared
the terrible pity of his silence,
seem to be telling them that they had become one with him in their final
sacrifice.
They hadn't lived his life far from it,
but unknowingly they had died.
His death.
That's a part of the glory of the trenches that a man who has not been good can
crucify himself and hang beside Christ in the end.
So you're out on the battlefield and you sacrifice your life,
you will,
all of your sins are gone.
You're washed away and you,
you hang beside Christ in the end.
God,
as we see him and do we see him?
I think so,
but not always consciously.
He moves among us in the forms of our brother men,
we see him most evident.
We when danger is most threatening and courage is at its highest,
we often don't recognize him out loud.
Our chaps don't assert that there has fellow campaigners.
They're too humble minded and inarticulate for that.
So he's saying,
God's all around us.
I see in the guys there,
they're his campaigners,
but,
but they don't even,
they don't say that.
Don't say we're doing the work of God.
They don't say we're still living like God or we're living like Jesus Christ.
No,
they're too humble minded and inarticulate for that.
They're where they are because they want to do their bit.
They're duty.
Okay.
For carefully disguised.
Instinct of honor brought them.
They're doing their bit in Bible language means laying down their lives for
their friends,
doing their bit.
That covers everything.
Okay.
Here's an example of how God walks among us in one of our tax on the Somme,
all the observers up forward,
we're uncertain as to what had happened.
We didn't know whether our infantry had captured that are objective failed or
gone beyond it.
The battlefield as far as the eye could reach was a bath of mud
is extremely easy and the excitement of an offensive when all landmarks are
blotted out for our storming parties to lose their direction.
If this happens,
a number of May result of Italian may find itself up in the air,
which means that it failed to connect with the battalions on it's left and
right.
It's flanks are then exposed to the enemy.
It may advance too far and start digging itself in at a point where it was
previously arranged that our artillery should place their protective wall of
fire.
Yeah.
We being forward artillery advert observers are the eyes of the army.
It is our business to watch for such contingencies to keep in touch with the
situation as it progresses and to send our information back as quickly as
possible.
Okay.
We were peering through our glasses from our point of vantage when far away in
the thickest of the battle smoke,
we saw white flag waving,
sending back messages.
The flag waving was repeatedly desperate.
It was evident that no one had replied and probable that no one had picked up
the messages of signal who was with us,
read the language for us.
A company of infantry had advanced too far.
They,
they were,
most of them wounded,
very many of them dead and we're in danger of being surrounded.
They asked for artillery to place a curtain of fire in front of them and for
reinforcements to be sent up,
so they're in their trench there.
The artillery guys,
they're looking out,
they see flag,
which is how they,
one of the methodologies they had for signaling and communicating.
You do these different signals and you could spell out words and so they're
getting a signal back from this group that they might get surrounded.
We need some artillery support in here.
We at once phoned the orders through to our artillery and notified the infantry
headquarters of the,
of the division that was holding the front,
but it was necessary to let those chaps know that we were aware of their
predicament.
They'd hang on if they knew that otherwise
without orders are signaler was getting his flags ready.
He hopped out.
He hopped out onto the trench.
Yeah,
he hopped out of the trench and onto the parapet.
He didn't stand a 50 50 chance.
The Hun was familiar with our observation station at strafed it with persistent
regularity.
The signaler turned to the senior officer present.
What shall I send them?
Tell them their messages have been received and that help is coming
out.
The chap scrambled a flag in either hand.
He was nothing but a boy.
He ran crouching like a rabbit to a hump of mud,
whereas figure would show up against the sky.
Is flags commenced to waving messages received help coming?
They didn't see him at first.
He had to repeat the words.
We watched him breathlessly
yeah,
we knew what would happen at last.
It did happen.
[inaudible] observers spotted him and flash the target back to his guns.
All about the mud commence to leap up and bubble.
Yeah,
he went down signaling the good word to those stranded men upfront message
received help coming.
At least they'd seen him.
They were signaling,
okay.
It was at that moment that a Whiz Bang lifted him off his feet and landed him
all of a huddle.
His bit,
it was what he'd volunteered to do when he came from Canada.
The signal,
okay.
In the battle smoke was like a testimony to his character.
So like I said,
this had to be a common attitude and it's just hard for us to understand this
and it's hard for me that was in the military for 20 years to understand this
attitude that you know what?
It's your time to die now,
step up and go pass this signaling back to them.
And I'm not saying that,
you know,
modern military guys don't take risks.
Obviously you take enormous risks and we've got taken drastic casualties,
but it is,
this is definitely a different mentality.
There's no doubt about it.
I mean,
obviously it's a different mentality when you're losing
millions of men,
millions of men.
Back to the book,
and this is,
this is fast forward a little bit to kind of just giving a little more insight
about what their outlook was out there in France.
We used to tell each other fairy tales of how we would spend the first year of
life when the war was ended.
One man had a baby who had never seen another girl whom he was anxious to marry.
My dream was more prosaic,
but no less ecstatic.
It began and ended with a large white bed and a large white bath.
For the first 365 mornings after peace had been declared,
I was to be awakened by the sound of my bath.
Being filled.
Water was to be so plentiful that I could tumble off to sleep again without even
troubling to turn off the tap in France.
One has to go dirty so often that the dream of always being cleaned seems as
unrealizable has romance.
Our drinking water is frequently brought up to us at the risk of men's lives,
carried through the mud and petrol can strap to pack horses to use it carelessly
would be like washing in men's blood.
And here's another little paragraph about,
again,
giving some more insight.
You wouldn't think that the men who would go to war to learn how to be kind,
but they do.
Okay.
There's no kinder creature in the whole wide world and the average Tommy,
he makes a friend of any stray animal he can find.
He shares his last frank with a chap who isn't his pal.
He risks his life to die in.
Consequently to rescue anyone who's wounded,
he's gone over the top with the bomb and bay and net for the express purpose of
doing in the Hun,
but he makes a comrade of the Fritzy he captures.
You'll see him coming down the battered trenches with some scarred lad of a
German at his side.
Now he has,
as I said in the beginning of this are we,
he gets wounded and it,
at this point he's been wounded and now he's heading to Blighty,
which we talked about this before on the podcast,
but bloody was slang for going back to England.
Hmm.
Back to the book.
Never my never in all my fortnight's journey to blighty.
Did I hear a word of self pity or complaining?
So he's going with a bunch of wounded people.
He's not hearing any complaining.
On the contrary,
the most severely wounded men would profess themselves grateful that they had
gotten off so lightly since the war started.
The term lightly has become exceedingly comparative.
I suppose a man is justified in saying he's got off lightly when what he
expected was death.
Yeah.
I remember a big Highland officer who'd been shot in the knee cap.
He'd been operated on and the knee cap had been found to be so splintered.
It had to be removed of this.
He was unaware for the first day as he lay in bed.
He kept wondering aloud how long it would be before he could rejoin his
battalion.
Perhaps he suspected his condition and was trying to find out all his heart
seems set at once on getting back into the fighting.
Next morning he plucked up the courage to ask the doctor and received the
answer.
He had dreaded never.
You won't be going back old chap.
Next time he spoke,
his voice was a bit throaty.
We'll it's stiffen.
You've lost the knee joint.
The doctor said,
but with luck we'll save the leg.
Has a voice sank to a whisper?
If you do,
it won't be much good,
will it
not much said the doctor.
He lay for a couple hours silent,
readjusting his mind to meet the new conditions.
Then he commenced talking with cheerfulness about returning to his family.
The habit of courage had the habit of courage,
which grows out of the knowledge that you let your pals down by showing
cowardice.
So it took him a couple of hours to adjust,
said,
okay,
looks like I get to go back to my family.
Now we have another type of casualty here talking about men that have had major
disfigurements to their faces
and their,
they would wrap.
Their whole face is up.
Back to the book.
In these days that followed,
I saw several of these masked men,
the worst cases we're not allowed to walk about.
Okay.
The ones I saw were in variable and variably dressed with the most scrupulous
care in the smartest uniforms.
Sam Browns,
the best.
The belt that goes over your shoulder,
polished buttons shining.
They had hope and took a pride in themselves.
A splendid sign.
Perhaps you ask why the faces kept,
the face cases should be kept in France.
So they,
the guys that had major facial did a disfigurement.
They would stay in France.
Hmm.
I was not told,
but I can guess because they dread going back to England to their girls until
they had got rid of their disfigurements.
So for two years through their bandages,
they watched the train pullout for blighty.
While the damage which was done to them in a fragment of a second is repaired
at a base hospital.
You see something,
what you don't see at casualty stations,
sisters,
mothers,
sweethearts and wives sitting beside the beds,
they're allowed to come over from England when their man is dying.
One of the wonderful things to me was to observe how these women in the hour of
their tragedy catch this soldier spirit.
Okay?
They're very quiet,
very cheerful,
very helpful.
While while passing through the ward,
they get to know some of the other patients and remember them,
okay?
When they bring their own man flowers,
sometimes when their own man is asleep,
they slip over to other bedsides and do something kind for the solitary fellows.
That's the army all over.
Military discipline is based on unselfishness.
These are women who have been sent to see their men die catch from them.
The spirit of on distressed sacrificed and enroll themselves as soldiers.
Okay?
You discover the spirit of man when you've heard him wandering in delirium,
so he's talking a little bit about the obviously guys that are suffering from
shell shock is what they call it,
what they used to call it in world war one.
Guys that are having some mental issues all night in the shadow reward with it's
occluded lamps.
Q would be giving orders for the comfort of his men.
Sometimes he'd be proposing to go forward himself to a place where a company was
having good hot time.
Apparently one of his officers was trying to dissuade him.
Danger be damned.
He'd exclaim in a wonderfully strong voice.
It'll buck them up to see me.
Splendid Japs,
splendid chaps
for the soldier.
It seems that the war has always been and that they will never cease to being
soldiers for them both the fast,
the past and the future are utterly obliterated.
They would not have it otherwise because they are doing their duty.
They are contented.
Okay.
The only time the subject is ever touched on,
he's when someone expresses the hope that it will last long enough for them to
recover from his wounds can get back to the line.
That usually starts another man who will never be any good,
never be any more good for the trenches,
wondering whether he can get into the flying corps.
But one ultimate hope of all these shattered rex who are being hurried to
blighty they have dreamt of is that they may see service again.
And we still hear that.
We still hear that to this day.
We still hear that.
And I heard that,
you know,
I,
I talked about hearing that from Ryan job who was blind and he's back in
American.
He's like,
let me come back.
My first guy that I ever had would get wounded bad and,
and I,
I went to see him in the,
in the medical outstation and I just went down to like shake his hand and he was
on morphine,
you know,
he'd been shot in the leg.
He's didn't know if he's going to lose his leg or not.
And like I went down and gave,
you know,
I,
I like went to shake his hand and he pulled me in and he's like,
let me stay.
And I was just like,
you man.
What an awesome brother right there.
So this is not rare.
This still happens.
And you know,
you hear this all the time and you know what we,
there's guys in the u s military that,
oh,
go back to combat with,
you know,
one leg with one hand.
Uh,
I mean even Jody was like talking about,
you know,
when he woke up and found Jody medical who did the podcast with,
and when he woke up and he found out that they took both of his legs,
he was pissed because one leg,
you can still go back deployment,
but two bad you can't do it.
So Jody,
the bad ass,
it was just like,
no,
look.
Well,
how am I going to go back now?
Yeah.
Some of us will be back in the fighting and jolly glad of it.
Others are doomed to remain in the trenches for the rest of their lives.
Not the trenches of the front line where they've been strafed by the hun,
but the trenches of physical curtailment where self pity we'll launch wave after
wave of attack against them.
It won't be easy
not to get the wind up.
It'll be difficult to maintain normal cheerfulness.
Yeah,
but they're not the men they were before they went to war out there.
They've learned something there.
Game.
Okay.
They'll remain soldiers,
whatever happens.
So he's talking about these guys that are aren't compelled to make it back and
he's saying there it's going to be hard for him
but he's saying that their game when they're going to bring it,
cause there were going to remain soldiers regardless of what happens.
Now this is a pretty interesting piece where he goes back to New York or like I
said,
he had spent some time there and he started,
he's talking a little about about what it's like in New York.
He says there's one person I've missed since my return to New York.
I've caught glimpses of him disappearing around corners but he dodges.
I think he's a bit of shame to meet me.
That person is my old civilian self.
What are full blown ego is to use to be how full of golden plans for his own
advancement,
how terrified of failure of disease,
of money,
losses of death,
of all the temporary external,
nonessential things that have nothing to do with this spirit.
Okay.
War in itself is damaged.
It's an extravagant wasteful use of resources.
A misuse of accumulated brain stuff of centuries.
Yeah.
Nevertheless,
there's many.
A man who has no love of war,
who previous to the war had cramped his soul with the littleness and was chased
by the bayonet of duty into the blood stain,
largeness of the trenches,
who has learned to say thank God for this whore.
He thinks God not because of the carnage,
but because when the wine press of new ideals was being trodden,
he was born in an age where he could do his share.
Often at the front,
I've thought of Christ's explanation of his own on a sailor Google piece,
an explanation given to his disciples had the last supper be of good cheer.
I have overcome the world.
Overcoming the world as I understand it,
is overcoming fear.
Fear,
and it's final analysis is nothing but selfishness.
A man who is afraid in the attack isn't thinking of his pals,
of his pals and how quickly terror spreads.
He isn't thinking of the glory which we will accrue to his regimen or division
if the attack is a success.
He isn't thinking of what he can do to contribute to that success.
He isn't thinking of the splendor of forcing his spirit to triumph over
weariness and nerves and the abominations that the huns are chucking at him.
He's merely thinking of how he can save his award,
flawless skin,
and conduct his entirely unimportant body to a place where there aren't any
shells
in London.
As I saw the work a day,
unconscious nobility of the maimed and wounded,
the words I have overcome the world took an added depth.
All of these men have,
I have overcome the world.
Look in their faces.
It is comparatively easy for a soldier with traditions and ideals to get back
to face death,
calmly to be calm in the face of life as these chaps are,
takes graver courage.
What has happened to them?
This attitude of mind or greatness of soul,
whatever you like to call it was learnt in the trenches where everything outward
is polluted and damageable
their experience at the front has given them what in the army language is known
as guts,
guts or courage is an attitude of mind towards calamity and attitude of mind,
which makes the honorable accomplishing of duty more permanently satisfying than
the preservation of self.
Like I said,
when I kicked this off,
this is a different,
it's a powerful angle to look at these things in.
And I have talked about this as well and I don't know if you,
Sam Harris asked me,
hmm,
you know,
I was saying that,
hey,
war shows you a lot of beauty in that Geez,
where you just get to see these incredible capacity of humanity.
And he said,
yeah,
you know,
you say that,
but I've also heard you describe war as as horrible.
And you know,
I kind of gave him an answer about,
uh,
you know,
I asked him,
I said,
hey,
if,
have you ever known any bit survived cancer?
And he said yes.
And I'm like,
yeah.
And when they survive it,
a lot of them say it,
it opened my mind,
it freed me from being afraid and it did all these wonderful things and I'm not,
I would never wish it on anybody,
but
they don't,
they don't wish that it didn't happen either.
They learn so much from it.
And that's how I feel about war.
And that's kind of what,
what I read in a lot of this is Dawson saying,
look,
you are so changed by this.
And regardless of the horrors,
the change is positive and it opens your eyes in a way that nothing else can.
Okay.
Back to the book.
That's the kind of people,
God,
we got on the western front.
It isn't a sad peep either.
When men die for something worthwhile,
death loses all its terror.
It's petering out in bed from sickness or old age.
That's so horrifying.
Okay.
Many a man who's cowardice is at loggerheads with his sense of duty comes to the
front as a noncombatant.
He compromises with his conscious and takes a bomb proof job in some service
whose place as well behind the lines.
So he's saying like,
okay,
a lot of guys,
they're like,
hey,
you know what?
I'm kind of scared.
I don't know.
I just want it,
you know,
just gimme a gimme an easy job,
I don't want to get killed
back to the book.
He doesn't stop there long.
If he's a decent search sort,
having learnt more than he ever guests before about the brutal things that shell
fire can do to you.
He transfers into a fighting unit.
Why?
Because danger doesn't appall it.
Allures he holds a challenge.
It stings one's pride.
It urges one to seek out a sending scales of risk just to prove to himself he
isn't flabby.
Yeah.
And fiber is actually another word that I looked up.
There's an old,
uh,
kind of capture what the real meaning is.
And then there's the definition.
Another definition is lacking strength or determination.
Okay?
Now this is,
this is classic.
The safe job is the only job for which there's no competition in fighting units.
You have to persuade
men to be grooms or cooks or Batman.
If you're seeking volunteers for a chance at a [inaudible],
you'll have to cast lots to avoid the offense of rejecting,
okay?
All of this is in explicable to civilians.
And again,
this is something I saw with my own two eyes and I talked about this in my
retirement speech and Ramadi,
where I was like,
okay,
we need volunteers who wants to go over and live in this hell hole in eastern
Ramadi and go out on operations where we're going to be taking casualties.
It's going to be a nightmare.
And I can promise you nothing but blood,
sweat,
and tears.
Who if you want to go on that,
if you want to go there,
not,
not for one operation,
but I'm gonna put you there for six months.
So who you know,
if you want that,
put your name on the board.
Every single guy does it.
And that's exactly,
that's exactly what he's talking about here.
It's exactly.
As a matter of fact,
I hooked up with this trooper down in New Zealand,
did Jujitsu player and uh,
we were talking to you,
he said he was in the using the room,
um,
in the commandos and a Royal Marine commandos,
40 commando,
and he was going to get moved to being a cook Frisco for your duty as a cook is
what he was going to get tasked with.
And he got out,
he got out of them,
read,
got out of the room rents because we know what is,
I'm going to be a cook,
you know,
I'm a,
I'm a warrior.
I want to go and get after it.
So it's like you see that did this modern day,
you know what I'm talking about,
how different it was back then,
but maybe it wasn't as different as I think it is.
Yeah.
Because we still got troopers that are just willing to step up all the time.
And that's,
that's one thing.
That's awesome.
You know what,
again,
from my experience in the,
in the,
in the seal teams,
you know,
when I went,
when it went in,
there was no war going on.
I kind of thought that there was,
but there wasn't.
But these guys,
these kids that come in now they know where they're going.
They know there's a war going on.
They know they're going to get after it.
And there
the lining up.
I know,
man.
It's crazy how many people I see their reason to join is to go fight these bad
guys.
It's not cause I don't have anything better to do or not.
It's like Nah,
I want to,
I want to quit my job and go fight.
Yeah,
there's no doubt about it.
No doubt about it.
Now I like this cause we start hammering on some philosophers a little bit.
No offense to a Daryl Cooper and martyrmade cause he's big philosophy guy.
I know,
I know where you're at.
Cooper.
Um,
I'm going to,
I'm going to agree with Dawson on this one.
So here we go back to the book.
If civilian philosophers fail to explain us,
we can explain them
in their world.
They are the center of their universe.
They look inward instead of outward,
the sun rises and sets to minister to their particular happiness.
If they die,
okay,
the stars would vanish.
Okay?
We understand.
A few months ago we too were like that.
Okay?
What makes us reckless of death is our intense gratitude that we have altered.
We want to prove ourselves and access how utterly changed.
Yeah,
we are from what we were
in his secret heart.
The egoist is a self despisers.
Can you imagine what a difference it works in a man after years of self
contempt,
at least for one brief moment to approve of himself.
Ever since we can remember,
we are chained to the prison house of our bodies.
We live to feed our bodies,
to close our bodies,
to preserve our bodies,
to minister to their passions.
Now we know that our bodies are mere flimsy shells in which our souls are
paramount.
Okay?
We can fling them aside any minute they become ignoble.
The moment the soul has departed,
we have proof.
Okay?
Often at zero hour,
we have seen whole populations of cities go over the top and vanish.
Okay.
Leaving behind their bloody rags.
We should go mad if we did not believe in immortality.
We know that the physical is not the essential part.
How better can a man shake off his flesh that at the hour when his spirit is
most shining,
the exact day when he dies does not matter tomorrow or 50 years.
Hence the vital concern is not win.
But how
the civilian philosopher considers what we've lost,
he forgets.
Okay
that it could never have been ours for a long
given up the self.
You know this is,
there's some zen and I'm no Buddhist monk,
but there's a lot of zen philosophy in there too.
You're completely surrendering yourself.
Yeah.
And that's a powerful,
powerful thing.
You look like you really liked that last part there.
It's heavy stuff.
And here's here,
he kind of goes down the same vein cause he's comparing civilian life and so he
just was talking about civilian philosophers and now he's going to go into just
talking about the civilian even even how
civilian spend their life.
And how he used to spend his life.
Hmm.
Yeah.
So here we go.
Back to the book,
we probably caught a train and every morning the same train,
we went to a business where we sat at a desk.
Neither of the business nor the desk ever altered.
We received the same strafing from the same employer or if we were the employer,
we administered the same strafing.
We only did these things that we might eat bread our dreams,
we're all selfish.
Oh,
for more clothes,
more respect,
more food.
Bigger houses.
Okay.
The least part of the day we vote,
devote to the people and the things we really cared for
and the people we loved,
we weren't always even nice to them.
Yeah.
Then then he breaks and he goes into what?
What it is being a soldier.
He says being a soldier is doing a man's job,
doing it for someone else and on afraid to meet God,
and now he's about to go in and discuss where this comes from.
Nevertheless,
it is true.
It isn't natural to be brave.
How then have multitudes of men acquired this sudden knack of courage?
They have acquired it through discipline and training.
When you have subjected yourself to discipline,
you ceased to think of yourself.
You are not you,
but part of a company of men.
If you don't do your duty,
you throw the whole machine out.
You soon learn the hard lesson that every man's life and every man's service
belongs to other people
of this.
The Organization of an army is a vivid illustration.
Take the infantry,
for instance,
they can't fight by themselves.
They're dependent on the support of the artillery.
The artillery in turn would be terribly crippled were it not for the gallantry
of the air service.
If the infantry collapse,
the guns have to go back.
If the infantry advanced,
the guns have to be pulled forward.
This close interdependence of service on service division,
on division battalion on battery follows right down through the army till it
reaches the individual so that each man feels that the day will be lost if he
fails.
His imagination becomes intrigued by the immensity of the stakes for which
he plays
any physical calamity which may happen to himself,
becomes trifling when compared with the disgrace.
He would bring upon his regimen if you are not courageous.
Yeah.
Now I'm about to read them a piece that's,
it's just a story he tells.
It's a story within a story.
Hmm.
Yeah,
and we'll go right to it.
A few months ago I was handling,
oh,
I was handing over a battery position in a fairly warm place.
The major who came up to take over for me brought with him a subaltern and just
enough men to run the guns.
We're going to half an hour of their arrival.
A stray shell came in and caught the subaltern and five of the gun detachment.
Okay.
It was plain at once that the subaltern was dying.
His name must have been written on the shell.
As we say in France.
We got a stretcher and made all haste to rush him out.
Okay.
To addressing station.
Just as he was leaving,
he asked to speak with his major.
I'm sorry sir.
I didn't mean to get wounded.
He whispered.
The last word he sent back from the dressing station where he died was telled a
major.
I didn't mean to do it.
That's the discipline.
He didn't think of himself.
All he thought of was that as major would be left shorthanded
when he's about to tell another story.
That is,
yeah.
Well,
I'm just going to read it.
Last spring,
the night before and attack a man was brought into battalion headquarters,
dug out under arrest,
the colonel and the adjutant.
We're busy attending the last details of their preparations.
The adjutant looked up irritably.
What is it?
Okay.
The NCO of the guard answered.
We found this man sir,
in a communication trench.
His company has been in the front line for two hours.
He was sitting down with his equipment thrown away and evidently has no
intention of going up
the adjutant glance coldly at the prisoner.
Okay,
what have you to save for yourself so you understand this.
So there's a there.
They found the soldier,
he was,
his troops were up,
been fighting on the front line for two hours.
Big Find Him.
He's got his radio strewn about and they say,
are you going to go fight with your man?
And he says he's not going to go.
So the agile glance,
Colby at the prisoner,
what have you to say for yourself?
The man was ghastly white and shaking like an aspen,
sir.
I'm not the man I was since I saw my best friend Jimmy with his head blown off
and lying in his hands.
It's kind of got me,
I can't face up to it.
The adjutant was silent for a few seconds.
Then he said,
you have a double choice.
You can either be shot up there doing your duty or behind the lines as a coward.
It's for you to choose.
I don't care.
The interview was ended.
He turned again to the colonel.
The man slowly straightened himself,
saluted like a soldier and marched out alone to the front.
That's what discipline does for a man who's going back on himself.
And like I said,
I'm not even,
I'm not even sure how I feel about that story.
I actually don't know.
Um,
you know,
you got a guy in Itto Hackworth talks about this.
Dick winters talked about this,
where you get guys that they're broken and you got to give him a break and you
know,
what has this guy been through?
God only knows,
you know,
obviously he saw his friend get killed.
I'm sure he was near death and over and over again.
And the colonel just says,
nope.
You either get out there and die or you die back here as a coward.
It's,
it's,
you know,
I'm,
I'm kind of,
there's like a part of me that is,
that is filled with admiration.
Cause the guy obviously overcomes his fears and there's also a part of me that's
filled with horror because he overcomes his fierce.
Yeah.
And to give that,
to give that final order and for the soldier to give that final salute.
It's just all of it.
The bravery and at the same time the callousness and at the same time the fear
and at the same time the courage and the dedication to duty and yet its
dedication to madness.
Yeah.
And again,
it's,
it's a window into human nature.
Hmm.
Okay.
And what people go through and what people will do and won't do it,
what it takes to get them there.
Back to the book,
one of the big influences that helps keep a soldier soul sanitary is what's
known in the British army as spit and Polish
directly.
We pull out for rest,
we start to working burnishing and washing.
The chaps may have shown the most brilliant courage and self sacrificing
endurance.
It counts for nothing if they're untidy the first morning,
no matter what are the weather conditions,
we hold an inspection.
Every man has to show up with his chin,
shaved hair cut,
leather polished and buttoned shining.
Okay?
If he doesn't,
he gets Hell
No.
I mean clearly we've talked about this since day one.
The discipline and maintaining the discipline and here these guys coming off the
front lines from the trenches.
Alright,
cool.
Tomorrow morning we're having inspections or get your deer together and Polish
your boots.
Okay.
Back to the book.
There's a lot in it.
You bring a man out from a tight corner where he's been an hourly contact with
deaf.
He's apt to think what's the use and taking pride in myself.
I'm likely to be done in any day.
It'll all be the same if I'm dead,
but if he doesn't keep clean in his body,
he won't keep clean in his mind.
Okay.
The man who has his buttons shining brightly in his leather polished is usually
the man who is brightly polished on the inside.
Spit and Polish teaches a man to come out of the trenches from seeing his pals
killed and carry on as though nothing abnormal had happened.
Okay.
It educates him in an impersonal attitude towards calamity,
which makes it bearable.
Okay?
It forces him not to regard anything to tragically.
If you can stand aside from yourself and poke fun at your own tragedy and
tragedy always has.
It's humorous aspects that helps.
We were sometimes we were in the soum for several months.
The mud was up to our knees almost all the time.
We were perishingly cold and very rarely dry.
There was no natural cover.
When we went up forward to observe,
we would stand in water to our knees for 24 hours rather than going to the dug
outs.
They were so filled with vermin and batten flies,
wounded and straight.
Men often drowned on their journey back from the front line.
Many of the dead never got buried.
Lives couldn't be risky in carrying it them out.
We were so weary at the site of those who rested forever,
only stirred in asa quiet envy.
Our emotions were too exhausted for hatred.
They usually are,
unless some new hunnish snus had roused them.
Okay.
When we were having a bad time,
we'd glance across no man's land and say,
poor old fritzy.
He's getting the worst of it.
That thought helps,
and this is a piece where he talks about when somebody's not holding the line,
when somebody is a quitter,
when you come to consider it a quitter is always a selfish man.
It's selfishness that makes a man a coward or dessert,
or if he's in a dangerous place and runs away,
all he's doing is thinking of himself.
Okay?
And he goes on to say,
here,
I've been supposed to have been talking about God as we see him.
Okay.
I don't know whether I have,
as a matter of fact,
if you asked me when I was out there,
whether there was any religion in the trenches,
I should have replied.
Certainly not.
Yeah.
Now that I've been out of the fighting for a while,
I see that there is religion there a religion which will dominate the world when
the war has ended.
The religion of heroism.
Okay.
It's a religion in which men don't pray much with me.
Before I went to the front,
prayer was a habit out there.
I lost the habit.
What one was doing seemed sufficient.
Yeah.
I got the feeling that I might be meeting God at any moment,
so I didn't need to be worrying him all the time,
hanging on to spiritual telephone and feeling slightly slighted if he didn't
answer me directly when I rang him up.
Okay.
If God was really interested in me,
he didn't need constant reminding.
When he had a world to managed,
it seemed best not to interrupt him with frivolous petitions,
but to put my prayers into my work.
That's how we all feel out there.
I've learned discipline and my own total unimportant.
Okay.
In the army,
discipline gets possession of your soul.
You learned to suppress yourself,
to obey implicitly to think of others before yourself.
You learn to jump at an order to forsake your own convenience at any hour of the
day or night to go forward on the most lonely and dangerous errands without
complaining,
okay?
You learn to feel that there is only one thing that counts in life and only
thing you can make out of it.
The spirit you have developed in encountering difficulties.
Your body is nothing.
It can be smashed in a minute.
How frail it is.
You never realize until you've seen men smashed.
So you learn to tolerate the body,
to despise death and to place all your alliance on courage,
which when is found at its best is the power to endure for the sake of others.
Okay?
He
closing out here.
The religion of the trenches is not a religion which analyzes God with in
pertinent speculation.
So,
so in this religion,
in the trenches,
God is not standing in some kind of,
in a fourth Terrian judgment.
It isn't a religion which takes up much of his time.
It's a religion which teaches men to carry on stout be and to say,
I've tried to do my bit as best I know how
that's the simple religion of the trenches as I have learnt it a religion not
without glory.
Yeah.
To carry on as bravely as you know how and to trust God without worrying him.
And the last line I'll read from the glory that trend,
Dawson says,
it's funny,
you go away to the most damn Umble undertaking ever invented
and you come back cleaner in spirit.
Yeah.
Then
again,
I will tell you that from my perspective and from what I've been through,
which by the way,
I want to say that what I've been through in my military career is absolutely
nothing.
Nothing compared to what a soldier in World War One lived through.
But what I did go through,
I will say this,
I don't think war took anything away from me or impacted me in a negative way.
I think war made me better.
I think war made me a man,
a better person.
And in the words of Dawson,
I think it absolutely cleaned my spirit
and I am.
I am thankful for that.
And I guess that the question becomes how can we clean our spirits without war?
How can we do that?
And I think the answer again,
and this is something that I don't mean that I think
okay,
is that it comes from discipline.
That's what I talk about it all the time.
It's about setting aside comfort,
setting aside weakness,
setting aside fear in having the discipline to endure.
I mean door,
the challenges and the hardship and the pain in order to become better,
to,
to suffer the glory of the discipline
to become stronger and faster and smarter and better
and and now from a leadership perspective
is to then put,
put others before yourself
the try and do some good in the world for others to lead them down the right
path.
Not,
not for you,
but for them.
And while war certainly taught me those things and ingrained those things into
my mind,
if they weren't already there,
I don't think you need to go to a war told her no.
But I do think that you have to discipline yourself and you have to get outside
your comfort zone and you have to push yourself beyond what you thought you
could ever do
to get
to get that glimpse
of the truth and to get that glimpse
of the glory
in the trenches
heavy one.
Yeah.
And again,
thanks to Jesse for sending me this book,
outstanding old copy printed in 1918 and I actually
typed it all out so I didn't have to mess up this beautiful book.
I learned a lot from it,
so I appreciate it.
And
Echo Charles
saved me and talk.
Talk about something more like for instance.
Yeah,
but like for instance,
people just listen to this and uh,
maybe they want to listen to more of it.
Sure.
How could they help that occur in the world?
Help move that process along?
We could or we could just talk about Jocko white tea for like 10 minutes.
We could definitely talk about Daca wasn't really that into Dell.
I actually,
I was,
I'm into tea every once in a while and I can wait.
You said a lot of the tea from the office is now missing,
but you know,
like you're like,
ah,
you know,
it's a mellow night.
I should just call it and go to bed or something.
Then I'd make like,
you know what,
what's the mellow one Kemah meal or whatever.
Yeah,
I'm not into t like I said.
So I was like,
all right,
well,
Hey Jocko tea.
It's cool.
I'm cool.
How's that working out?
Don't write in.
It was like a random Saturday and I was like,
Hey,
I'm going to do like how you do,
put it on ice and see if I can't get my refresh on,
you know,
outside of whatever.
And um,
so I put it in,
I put in this tent,
Colorado's nice man.
I'll say,
Ooh,
I think I might be into tea a little bit.
Sarah comes out,
she has hers too.
It was nice.
It was cool man.
We are going through it
very quickly because their whole family is getting after it right now.
My younger kids.
But yeah,
and you know what's awesome?
I Dunno if you've a go go on to amazon.com and read the reviews that people are
riding yet.
I'm actually gonna I'm going to have to bring out some of those and read them.
Awesome.
They're funny as hell and they're great.
So everyone that's writing reviews for Jocko t Jocko white tea.
Uh,
appreciate it.
It's awesome and gotten a lot of good feedback as well about,
you know,
everyone likes it tastes great and it makes you feel real good.
Heel makes you feel it's a little glory,
a little glory and a cup.
Little glorying up ice tea.
Oh,
looking over like the instructions.
So let me just in case he don't eat,
you don't read the instructions.
I think they're pretty straightforward.
I think if we've ever had tea,
people know.
But if you took the time to read the instructions,
this is what you would would read.
Brewing instructions,
boil eight ounces of water,
pour water over one bag of Jocko white tea,
brew for three to five minutes.
Enjoy over or enjoy
a hot or over ice.
Get after it.
So get after it is part of the instructions
in what's funny is when people are,
are,
it's,
it's real.
Like you really like have to get after it.
And so that's what,
that's what's funny is people are saying it's real,
it's real,
it's real.
There's some real stuff in there.
And when you get it in your brain,
you'll be like,
oh I'm going to go knock out some projects,
maybe do a little metcon,
maybe go get on the mat,
whatever.
You know,
it's just good.
Or I might just cruise by the pool.
We don't do that.
That's not getting half of it.
And that makes one of us,
I was getting an afternoon in the pool.
How about that?
I guess a year approved.
Approved.
No,
it's good.
And then,
um,
like I said,
it made me even more into t cause there's like,
you know,
it's like you get into,
well I did,
I'm not going to say this is what happens,
but I'm saying you're like,
okay,
I like this tea.
I like the brand.
You know,
and then you appreciate the experience when,
when it goes down,
you know,
you're more familiar with it now.
Now I want to see people drinking tea.
I'm like,
yeah,
some people have been like,
well some people emailed and said,
Whoa,
is it really like Jocko made this too.
I'm really
took like it took a few months to make,
cause they kinda,
I'd send back,
oh no,
make it a little bit more of this,
a little bit less of that.
And eventually when I got the the right combination,
then it was okay.
And what they're like,
okay,
well for marketing,
what do you want to do?
And I go,
Oh,
here's the marketing.
I'm mister marketing over here.
Put it in a black box.
Oh,
what should we call it?
I think of a good original title.
Jocko t how's that?
Okay.
So we've got Jocko white tea.
Good.
There it is.
And that's my marketing strategy.
No,
I like it.
Go hire a marketing company to come in and do an assessment of our customers.
Guess what?
Our customers are out to kick ass.
They don't want all this crap.
They want something that's gonna make them crush the world.
And so there you go.
We don't need to put any,
you know,
images of whatever on it.
Doing some kind of demographic studies on what kind of interests and you know,
who's what the target market,
the target market.
I don't care.
I know the target market is the target market is my people out there that are
getting after it.
There's a target market.
Nope.
There you go.
I just hope,
I just thought,
I hope this doesn't fall into the wrong ants.
What if criminal criminally minded people or people that are um,
you know,
have evil thoughts.
Maybe if they start drinking white tea,
we'd be in trouble.
We might have to bolster up and drink more white tea or they could switch over
to the old discipline equals freedom kind of situation.
And you know,
I'm just saying theoretically that could be something that might be good to
look.
This is good man.
Slipped.
Looks good.
Yup.
Good.
Yeah.
Alright,
cool.
Jocko white tea.
Yeah.
You can order on amazon.com after you click through,
click through.
Yeah.
Which we,
you know what,
there's a whole tail behind the click through right now.
Yeah.
It's kind of,
we have to make sure,
because that's one of the main ways to support the podcast is to click through.
But if in the past you saved,
oh,
first of all,
if you had the trooper,
the trooper tool is Nolan void.
We got shut down by Amazon.
It was,
let's just say they didn't really like it that much.
They didn't like it that much because I was,
I've been proven wrong in the world.
This is one of the Times I've been wrong.
There is such a thing as getting after it too much and apparently we were
getting after it.
Troopers were getting after it too much with the trooper tool,
so they shut down the trooper tool.
Okay.
So if you're still have the trip too.
I don't know if it still works,
but if it,
if you still have it and you think you're using it,
you're not,
you're not supporting the podcast.
Yeah.
So what you have to do,
and also if you have your old link saved that would click you into uh,
Amazon and you thought,
oh,
I just use this and I'll just save the,
what's that called a favor.
If you made it a favorite marvel for if you bookmarked it,
then you got to erase that bookmark.
You've got to go back to Jocko podcast.com or back to Jocko store.com and you've
got to make a new bookmark that has the new click through to Amazon so we can
get Amazon back in the game supporting the podcast.
Again,
it's not costing you anything.
All it's going to cost you is that short period of time to click through.
And that way we can support the podcast.
That way we can buy more knives for the table
and that's what we're looking to do.
And Amazon is not mad at us.
They were just like,
Hey,
the trooper tools too heavy.
It's too heavy.
It's like when,
uh,
what was,
what was that book we just did where the Germans were mad that the Americans
weren't getting after it too much.
Yeah.
This is unethical.
Like theoretically from Amazon's perspective,
like,
like the Nazis,
they thought,
man,
these guys are getting after it too much,
too little.
This trooper tool thing is we need to rest so there's no more true to go save a
new bookmark.
Jibo Cibella from,
from Dako podcast.com or from
the Jacka store.com.
Alright,
so that's good.
That was a man.
That was a really good analogy right there by the way.
The German,
the Nazis.
Yeah.
Was good.
I'm not trying,
I'm not trying to say it was fascist in what Amazon did because it wasn't we,
you know,
they're there.
It's a great point.
It actually really is truly a great program.
It really is a great program.
It's a very supportive of us and it's cool for Amazon because people are ordered
and stuff through Amazon.
I love buying stuff and doing it through our,
our website.
It makes me feel good.
It's like another excuse to just buy more books.
I'm my books at a ridiculous rate right now.
It's actually,
it's almost embarrassing how many books on buying right now.
Cause everybody recommends me a book and I used to say,
well maybe I'll take a look at it.
I don't have time to do that anymore.
Now I just order it.
Just bring it to me.
It's Amazon.
I want it today.
Yeah.
Is How cool is that?
Amazon prime.
Same Day delivery.
Bring me my books.
I'm getting some,
you know what else is cool is,
so I was going to mark up the book,
the glory that judges,
but I didn't want to mark it up obviously because it's an old beautiful copy.
So I bought a new one.
Okay.
Now when you,
when you buy these certain books from Amazon there,
they print them immediately.
Oh right,
right.
Yeah.
And so this book has got printed on the 22nd of September for me.
And then I had just ordered it so I could mark this one up.
It didn't arrive before I went on my trip,
so I did it on another coffee.
So anyways,
um,
yeah,
they,
they will put a lot of these books that we're bringing out that our rare books
that are old books that are out of print books,
they just reprint them.
So you can get a book printed,
they'll bring it,
they're the ones out here on the,
on the west coast or printed in San Bernardino,
California.
Sam Bird Do.
There you go and you order it.
They drive it down that day.
Boom.
Yeah.
I don't know what man,
I don't know how this awesome something.
Yeah.
Cool.
Well yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
If he,
if,
if you want to support this podcast in that
whey,
which is a great way and we really appreciate it.
That's awesome stuff.
It's,
it's,
it definitely helps us do what we do.
Yeah.
Thanks.
But yeah,
it's on [inaudible] dot com and Jocko podcast.com click through.
What other ways can people support this podcast?
Well,
obviously the obvious way.
Subscribe to it on,
on,
um,
on iTunes.
Right if you haven't already.
And then,
and also the youtube again and I say this all the time,
I'm putting more videos on there.
It's cool cause I'll put little excerpts,
you know,
where,
because people on Twitter and stuff,
there'll be like,
hey,
can you just isolate this one excerpt of,
you know,
the Mark Lee speech that,
just random ones.
They'll say,
or they'll be like,
hey,
release this excerpt.
I want to make a video.
You know,
and you can get the videos from youtube and stuff.
So it'd be like,
hey episode,
I don't know,
40 you know,
the last closing thing I said anyway,
so I'll put stuff,
not just excerpts,
but other videos other than the whole episode of the podcast
and when a lot of times when you do those,
sometimes there's just excerpts,
but sometimes there's other things happening in those excerpts.
Sure.
I mean sometimes you make full new video,
like the good video to where has this been come from?
Yes.
And I think just,
I'll speak for the voice of everyone else and myself included and everyone else
that's listening,
this podcast that's not named Echo.
I think we all want to see more videos.
That's me.
Okay.
And I'm trying to,
you know,
I'm trying to make that hint to you.
I think I've been making it to you for awhile.
I know it's hard work,
but,
um,
you know,
we're just trying to let you know,
we here on,
you know,
the listeners and the,
and the troopers here,
we all want to see a little bit more activity.
Yep.
And,
uh,
and I think I personally think that the more people are subscribing to youtube,
the more the more motivated you're going to get.
Yeah.
I hate to see relying on motivation.
No,
no,
no.
Because I don't,
I rely on that discipline.
Yeah.
And I wish you were like,
Hey,
you know what my discipline is I'm making you know,
one video every two weeks by and see that kind of discipline yet really from,
there you go.
All right,
well,
hey,
we're one step closer.
You don't expect it.
Maybe not today.
Maybe not tomorrow,
but I'm on it.
I'm on it.
I like that.
Speaking of being on it,
oh look what he did there.
Um,
okay.
So on it is supplements.
We all know that a lot of people,
a lot of people don't think that I work out just cause they don't,
they don't see me.
They hear my voice.
So like,
oh,
I could have,
it doesn't work out.
But Jocko obviously works out.
Jocko does sick take supplements so people are like,
oh yeah,
jock retakes,
Krill oil.
Jocko takes strong bone and Jock who takes alpha?
Brainy.
There you go.
It's strong.
One is from honest from on it.
Okay.
All right.
There you go.
So yeah,
these are actual supplements.
I take the exact same thing and not the strong,
but I sat for the strong,
I left one out.
What shroom tech.
Shroom tech is good.
And I actually,
we trained today in Sunday.
We trained today.
We trained today harder.
I did not take from tech today and I didn't feel like I brought my a game the
way I wanted to.
So it's too bad.
Yeah,
he was good enough.
But,
but you know,
like I was breathing Carter
good roles today.
Yeah.
Good.
Taylor.
Sure.
Yeah.
He's,
when does he compete?
Uh,
next week.
Yeah.
Yeah,
that's right.
Look very similar.
Yeah,
he's good man.
Yeah.
This early on too.
Even if you wasn't as early on
anyway,
we'll talk about Taylor does as soon.
Yep.
But yeah,
get gate on it has the best supplements.
We all know that all legit cause a lot of supplements straight up don't work.
They do.
Some supplements rely on the placebo effect.
Literally rely on that.
Like that's its effectiveness.
That's why it's effective because of police.
This placebo effect,
not on it.
You find out about their stuff on the website,
but if you want 10% off those supplements that you're going to get on
it.com/jacqueline 10% off.
Boom.
I like it.
So he had to do that man.
Support yourself at the same time.
That's what I like to think it.
And then how about those?
Uh,
my,
what the jock was store chocolate store has some new items.
So Hey,
this is weird.
If you look on Instagram,
you posted a picture today.
I did.
Yes.
But now today is relative because when this podcast comes out,
it won't be chair the time October 2nd.
Oh,
people are going to attract the date.
Okay.
Understood.
It's my dad's birthday,
by the way,
today.
Happy Birthday.
Aquas father,
Happy Birthday,
William Charles Jr Bravo,
Charlie.
But BC on call.
I Happy Birthday Dad.
Love you.
Um,
so on my dad's birthday,
Jocko posted a picture on Instagram October 2nd and one of the comments,
I just read it a little while ago.
Um,
it says,
hey,
where do I get that good shirt?
Or where do I get a Jocko shirt?
Oh,
that's an interesting question,
right?
Because there's only one place in the world you can get that chip and I,
and we say it a lot,
but nonetheless,
no one's obligated to listen to me talk about Jocko store.
Really.
People fast forward when they get to you talking about style.
I'm not surprised if people do.
I'm not sure.
Are they missing some nuggets?
They're missing some information,
some information.
I think they're missing some good times too,
potentially.
Sure.
Yes.
So how they gonna know it was bcs birthday.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Great Point.
Yeah.
So you're not going to know that.
So I would say so don't fast forward through these,
but do what you like.
You know what,
if you're on your way to go do some pull ups or something and you're like,
the book's done.
We're done with the book them do some pull ups
then
cool.
You know what's weird though,
when you listen to other podcasts while specifically like if you listen to Joe
Rogan's podcast,
which I,
which I do sometimes,
they're just straight talking.
Yeah.
Nicky,
which is,
which is what we're doing right now.
We are talking about,
it is enclosed around some subject matter cause we're talking about ways to
support the podcast.
So yeah,
but it's still,
like I said,
there's some nuggets in there that are important and even if they're not
important,
what's funny is even if they're not important,
they're in there,
they're the,
this is what I think is cool is when I,
when I got to travel a lot and I've been traveling and I'm starting to meet just
like troopers everywhere,
everywhere.
I was all over the world,
all the way from New Zealand to the east coast,
up and down the east coast.
I've meet meeting troopers everywhere and when I meet people,
all of a sudden it's like,
it's like friends that you have inside jokes with everybody I meet,
you know,
they make cracks about this and you know about that and it's all from the
podcast.
So that's kind of cool is not just,
hey,
get on here and get educated about life leadership,
business war.
You know what,
let's have some inside jokes that we can laugh at each other at one when I show
up at,
you know,
you're,
you're whatever you work to do some work myself.
When people come to the gym and they'll tell me good evening,
even if it's daytime,
oh,
good evening.
At least a quarter of the reviews for Jocko white tea.
We start off with good evening echo.
I don't even know what started that.
I mean obviously I said it.
I think you started it.
I absolutely started it,
but,
but at some point,
I mean,
I don't know how else to introduce you,
right.
Other than to say we're good evening,
you sorta just kept doing it.
Yeah.
And you,
your response is now standard too.
Well,
what else would I say?
You know?
Okay.
I guess you don't,
can't say much.
No.
Good.
Amen.
Could say how's it going to stick with good evening?
I think I like that.
There it is.
But to answer that question,
let's say it's,
let's say someone else had that question.
Where do I get a Jocko shirt?
I'll tell you where you get a jungle shirt.
Jocko store dot.
That's again,
love the marketing on that title for that creative.
It's a store from Jocko.
It's unlined.com.
[inaudible] DOT com.
Yes,
we have shirts there.
Uh,
we have travel mugs.
You know the kidney can you bring with you,
they're not the kind you can put your Jocko white tea.
Sure.
Yeah.
If you choose to.
Yes,
exactly.
And uh,
some,
some bumper stickers that are kind of cool.
They're on Jocko store.com as well.
Um,
there's some other sticks on there.
Cool.
We have patches.
Okay.
Here's the thing about the patch,
about batches.
Someone online setting.
Hey,
get the velcro patches and man,
I'm just not as familiar with the velcro patches.
We already had these other two batches.
One is a Jujitsu patch.
The other one is that you just patch,
but it's all purpose patch.
You know you can iron out on but you still it.
Then it's four inches by three inches.
The velcro patch.
I'm like,
that's a good idea that I'll go patch.
Let me get the same thing for,
it's four by three.
It's a velcro patch,
so it's cool for that.
But you explain to me those velcro patches are interchangeable.
The standard is three by two,
three across.
So just understand the velcro patch currently right now is four by three.
Did you get to I threw in the ordered.
Yeah.
So I got to,
you know,
I didn't finalize it but they come in pretty quick.
So just know,
just be aware of the dementia of the patch if you want to do the interchangeable
one.
I guess technically you could put the four by three but we're not doing that.
Well,
I'll get the two by three and on.
Encourage that kind of,
yeah,
please.
Nonetheless,
they're on Jocko stores.
Well,
the Jujitsu patches there too.
Like I said,
her rash guards are there big time all on the job.
Go store somewhere on backorder,
but they're there in full effect for sure.
And they're good.
Yeah.
Five emails today
saying they felt the 19% performance allegedly there's no alleged about it.
Straight up,
legit.
How can you say that to legend when people at factually felt the difference that
that's just what being a skeptic.
It's what they said.
I wasn't there to witness it.
Oh,
where's he going to tell you they had a 19% improvement?
If they did not,
they alleged it that it was an allegation.
I don't support you on were fallen out of grace.
Your man.
When somebody tells me they got 19% improvement with the rash guard type,
get as fat.
Why would they lie to you?
Yeah,
you're right.
Otherwise they'd be saying,
Hey,
give me my money back.
I didn't get a 19% performance increase.
That's due two very good points.
And we have women's tank tops.
I understand fall,
we're going into winter soon.
Tank tops
or southern hemisphere people.
Sure.
Yeah,
the West,
because it's summer down there.
It's going to be summertime soon down in uh,
down in New Zealand and Australia and South America and the Hawaii people as
well from quiet.
We didn't know about that kind.
And that's what you,
where you were saying you don't understand what a Hoodie is from quiet like we
kind of,
we know what a Hoodie is.
We're making hoodies.
Yes.
So I mean we made with consultation from Jocko and some New England people,
we got hoodies on the way as well.
And women's tee shirts as well.
Yeah.
I was explaining to echo that in new England like a Hoodie is,
is like something you wear every single day for nine months out of the year.
You wear a Hoodie.
I'm waking up and putting on a Hoodie.
Yeah,
that's what,
that's what you do.
Yeah.
See.
So we've got to make sure we were going to make them awesome so that people will
be fired up and representing with their hoodie and they'll be toasty warm.
Yeah.
What's interesting,
for lack of a better term,
my wife is one of the those Hoodie people,
you know,
the kind of words to wear the Hoodie every single day.
Even when it's not cold.
She'll be like,
well it's like a comfort zone thing.
You know,
there's a bunch of them,
but I don't even know how many she even took Greg Trains Victory Hoodie and she
uses Alan.
That was like one of her many.
Anyway,
that's a good hook.
That was that.
Those are good hoodies.
Yeah.
Curious.
So,
um,
yeah,
so there it is.
We're going to have that coming out.
That should be within the next two to three weeks.
I think that's a fair amount of time to say and it'd be accurate.
Um,
so they,
ah,
there it is Jocko,
store.com in the event of you wanting to support this podcast in that way,
get some stuff,
give them us being two things,
whatever you want.
Once again,
appreciate all that support it.
Also if you want,
if you don't have a book that was written by a guy named Leif Babin,
my brother and myself,
we wrote a book called extreme ownership.
If you want to pick it up,
you can pick it up.
You'd get it on Amazon or anywhere else that they sell books and get,
we get so much good feedback on it.
It's awesome.
I appreciate all the positive feedback.
You know,
people read it and they say,
this really helped me,
you know,
not just with the way I'm doing my business,
but like with the normal stuff in the,
and
other cool thing is when people buy it for their team or they even buy it for
the boss sometimes.
So pick up extreme ownership.
We did the audio too.
If you want to read it,
if you don't want to read it cause you don't have time,
you just want to listen to it while you're in a,
in a traffic jam,
then just buy the audio book and you'll be good to go.
So appreciate that.
And then also if you dig that extreme ownership,
you dig that concept,
you can come out to a little something we're having here in southern California
in San Diego called the muster,
the extreme ownership muster.
We're going to be talking about leadership are going to be talking about how to
take the lessons that we learned in combat,
which had been proven in combat and how you can apply those same lessons doing
leadership in business leadership in life.
So we got a bunch of,
you are coming to us and it's awesome.
So,
and I had somebody email me the other day and it said said,
hey,
listen,
I just wanted to let you know I'm coming to the muster,
but in any event,
I don't get to meet you there.
Then,
uh,
you know,
I just want to let you know,
I really appreciate,
you know,
the podcast and the book and all that.
And I didn't even respond yet.
I don't think so.
I get a lot of emails,
but let me tell you something.
If you come to the muster where hanging out,
it's not going to be one of these gigs where you know,
I'm back in the green room waiting to go out.
Um,
getting in character.
Well No,
I,
this is my character and I won't be backstage.
I'll be in,
I'll be sitting at a table with you.
I'll be talking,
I'll be and laced can be doing the same thing.
So that's one of the major differentiators we want to have in this thing is that
because you know,
Lafe and I go to these events all the time cause we speak at them,
they'd,
you know,
leadership events and conferences and all that.
The biggest differentiator that we want to make is we want to be,
we want to have the contact that we want to have the face to face.
So if your common that not only are you gonna meet me,
we're going to kick it,
we're going to be hanging out,
we're going to be having dinner,
lunch,
we're going to be going over problems when we talk about solutions.
So don't think that I'm going to be,
um,
and that and that life is going to be all hiding in the background.
Now we're going to be there.
I'll be meeting you what we do in a workout.
Also,
some people want to try,
if you train legend Jitsu and you come out here,
come out here a little bit early or stay a little bit late and we're going to go
to the gym,
we're going to have a victory MMA and you can challenge Echo Charles to a death
match.
We'll be there.
Rolling.
So,
um,
you know,
if you,
if you stay,
if you stay Friday,
if you stay Saturday,
if you stay Sunday,
I will be there Friday night.
I'll be there Saturday day,
I'll be there Sunday day and we'll be getting it on.
So come on out for that,
for that muster and that'll be,
that'll be awesome.
Also if you can't come out to the muster,
but you just want to kind of kick it and keep these things going on and you want
to join the crew,
then all you've got to do is get on social media,
which,
which I didn't really understand social media a year ago,
you know,
I didn't know what it was all about.
But now what I know is I get to talk to people and I get to get to grow in my
knowledge from other people who,
who can communicate things,
who ask really good questions that I got to get research or I know an answer to.
And then they asked me something else.
And so,
so that's awesome.
And Funny Bunch of people post all kinds of funny self soul and getting
entertained and we're getting,
you know,
a crew and having a bunch of people there that are likeminded and is,
is,
is fun to have.
And so I appreciate it.
If you want to find us on social media,
echo is,
by the way,
he's at Echo Charles and that's on Instagram.
That's on Twitter.
That's on bath phase.
Bookie and I and I am also on social media and I am at Jocko Willink on Twitter,
on Instagram,
on Facebook.
I am also there and
I guess that's about it for this week.
We don't think we have time for the Q and.
A.
We'll push that in in the meantime.
You know,
again,
I know we got to,
I'm meeting people all over the place in.
Thank you.
Thank you all for supporting this podcast.
Thank you all for doing what you do.
Meet and firefighters working with firefighters and police officers.
Work with police officers,
the military folks that are emailing me,
the guys that are overseas right now fighting terror.
Thank all of you.
You all your uniform folks for what you do for holding the line overseas and
here at home and for everybody else that I'm mean,
I'm meeting people from all kinds of businesses.
All of you have goals.
You're trying to make things happen.
You're truck,
you're not calling,
you're not calling us up.
You're not calling Nathan I up unless you're trying to dominate.
So we love the fact that we get to go to places where you've got people that are
out there trying to kick ass,
trying to cut,
crush it.
And that's what propels America and keeps our country strong,
keeps our country free.
So thank you for what you're doing in all those jobs,
all you in the workforce.
It's awesome.
We appreciate it.
And there's one thing we want back from you and as we want to make sure that you
keep getting after it.
And so until next time,
this is echo and Jocko
out.